so when you start making your comeback
when you start climbing back into Show
Business you say that you had a vision I
did that you and Adam Sandler should be
together in a movie I knew or did you
see him more as like oh he should be my
boyfriend No in fact we never ever ever
nothing nothing not even a kiss were you
attracted to him that way I was so
attracted to his inner light right and I
think he's a handsome dude I he's ad you
didn't look at him that way you you said
I'm I want to be in a movie with him
because I think we'd have real chemistry
I want to be a modern weird like heper
Tracy old Hollywood couple I mean heper
and Tracy are a very different Dynamic
do you call him up and say look I'm Drew
Barrymore y I think if you and I got
together we would make great movies
together now he could have really
laughed you off and said hey I'm doing
great right now I don't need you honey
yeah he had like Happy Gilmore and Billy
Madison out and he was on SNL and every
girl I mean the girls loved him right um
all the girls were crazy about him you
had a meeting with Adam at a coffee shop
please come meet me I really need to
talk to you what did you say to him at
that meeting we looked like a frat boy
and a Picadilly circus ridiculous bad
combo don't you think about what you
wear when you go to meet with somebody
like hey I want to look acceptable again
this is who I am I had pink platforms on
I mean I was in my you know I I I was I
thought I look good right as soon as I
saw him I was like yeah you're probably
gonna have to see past all this and what
did you say you said hey if we make
movies together I believe they will be
hit movies it's something to that effect
but without being I've never been like
smug or like money oriented or big I
never use words like famous or money or
ambition or driven or success I'm like
the definition of success is employment
right you wanted to work as an actress I
was like listen I really believe that
you and I could get together and do
something meaningful Sandler then finds
a script for the two of you and he calls
you up I sent him something he didn't
respond to it he sent me uh a script
that didn't have a title and that was he
said I have an idea for this guy who
sings in a wedding band right and then
we carefully weaved together Carrie
fiser writing on it Jud appow Adam and
Tim Hurley Frank Karachi the director
and we layered this into a very even
piece I didn't know all those people
wrote on that yeah no it was a really
amazing collaboration the way that
script came together I knew that I
didn't want to just be a girl I wanted
always things to be equal two-handers
cuz those were the movies I loved where
people were really flushed out a lot of
these movies the girls just sort of like
oh yeah you're so great yeah she's there
you wanted to be in the movie yeah and I
would sit there and talk about you know
who is this guy and who is this girl
what is the story here and how do they
balance each other out and so you must
be so grateful to Adam for taking you
seriously when he could have had any
co-star and really developing something
he was hot he could have done
anything he wanted and he believed in me
and I believed in
him